so welcome everyone so as Michael
pointed out the talk is about some sort
of a merger of trying down
and how we can use biotechnology in a
rather interactive fashion and what this
kind of picture depicts here's right
like we have a human we see something
microscopically like cells under
microscope and reach you can see this
for a couple of centuries now like looks
through microscope and see what's going
on there but what really has eluded us
is to actually manipulate these
organisms or kind of flavor them and of
course like if you're in a research lab
you may be able to do it but kind of lay
people even like in a school setting
it's usually passive observation it's
not not kind of true into action and
this is kind of an inspiration for me
like a couple of years ago like this
justice thought like could we play games
with these sorts of cells and this kind
of led to many things even well beyond
anything that is intended to be gay more
playful so let's start here to kind of
also give credit to this audience so
what's the difference between these two
pictures and well videos O'Connor just
some balls once a lot smaller okay once
more with the agent training H yes maybe
the training easier they both have
interaction with technology in some way
okay I'll list all right so in most
cases you see humans interacting with a
computer there's about 50 years a
difference in time you see that this
machine here as much about number
crunching occasionally breaks down and
it's by far less powerful than what you
see here where even children can have a
very very interactive experience and so
you can say what you see on the on the
left is number crunching what you see on
the right is kind of an interactive
experience and if you not think about
recent developments in the life science
of biotechnology we can actually say
that many parallels what's going on now
in biotech versus what has been going on
in computer science or electronics a
couple of decades ago and just to make
this a little bit specific so what you
see here is to version of so-called
micropedic device as an example so here
on the simple one you see basically two
inlets white and the blue fluid and they
kind of merge and you see how droplets
form and how these droplets kind of move
around right and much more complicated
versions of that you see here which is
kind of like a integrated electronic
circuit but instead of moving electrons
around you move small fluid volumes
imagine for example you have a droplet
of blood put it in a device like this
and then the device is capable of doing
certain Diagnostics for you counting a
number of blood cells running certain
essays and so forth and these devices as
I said could use for Diagnostics to get
better and better in terms of their
capabilities use the logs and research
arm but have not yet hit so
unfortunately heels are kind of not
showing in the back have not yet really
entered the the consumer market but
they're kind of similarities in the way
tasting scale right and so this kind of
prompted this thought if we have now
these kind of technologies when do they
become interactive consumer friendly in
the same way as electronics become and
if they do so what could we do with them
right and just as a general side note
like lots of things that go on and
bioengineering can really look back at a
kind of computer science and being
inspired and certain things we can do
similarly other things work out
completely different and so for media
inspiration of that was the first one
electronics and computer science gave
rise to games why aren't we making games
and in the life sciences and the ideas
whatever then called biotic games is
like could we make games where human can
interact with the biological process or
material and this really has something
to with modern biotechnology so if it's
a pure emulation or pure simulation
that's not what I mean and also don't
mean something which is microscopic like
horse polo which is maybe more ancient
biotechnology right so that's not what
we interested in really thinking about
something that is kind of microscopic
and relying more on the modern
technology and what you see here is kind
of one of our first projects that kind
of shows the paradigm as such but you
just saw a single-celled organism of
paramecia this is like a very simple
microfluidic chip about a centimeter and
Wyatt and here see some electrodes and
if you apply mild electric fields and
actually this organism start following
these field lines and you can now bring
this whole thing in real time on a
computer screen and
then as you seen is insert kind of push
buttons and then move T cells around and
and play games in the sense for example
you have a virtually overlaid object and
the task is to kind of make the cells
move through this object right you could
either see this as just an interactive
experiment or you could see this as a
game okay and so this is kind of an
example of what interactivity means so
if we now just change the skin of this
right like putting other objects on top
of it and kind of changing the logic
then you can make other games so to
speak right like you have an underlying
game engine if you want to say but in
that case the game engine is something
real it's it's real cells okay um so
here again the device this kind of
rather simple I'd like this microchip
like a simple webcam and then just
brought on a on a regular computer and
putting some abstract objects on top of
this so what could we now do with that
and where should one go and one
inspiration for all of this is kind of
education I think lots of the initially
applications of our work will be in this
rearm and then it also talk later about
more serious type I mean educational
series but it kind of about other
applications that are beyond particular
education the one thing that always
fascinated me and from a life science
perspective also made me a little bit
envious if you look at other fields
they're really they really have cool
educational toys that are very
attractive right specifically in
mechatronics like kids building these
cool robots and a kind of these robotics
competitions around that they're really
supported by NSF and others to really
engage children students and kind of
learning technologies and then yes we
are more recently the equivalent
challenges here like the National video
game challenge with the idea hey kids
program games it's a fun activity but
thereby you become engaged with this
programming which is important skill to
have right and so could we take these
kind of things on these kind of ideas
basically in two lifetimes rearm with
our kind of interactive setups and so
this brings me to
a second project that we used try to
develop a similar system as I showed you
before but used organisms that are a
little bit more sturdy um that just
respond to light and developed a simple
microscope where you can actually play
these games on the phone and also having
the idea that you can actually build a
phone or a convertible set up yourself
and ever learn something about device
design so the organisms here are called
Euglena these are single-celled organism
about 50 micro meter in length so that's
half the size of a human hair they're
green so they do photosynthesis you have
this red I spot where the kind of sense
light so basically things just they can
just look in one direction and then you
have this long for gelam which kind of
makes them propel and swirls who the
fluid okay it's actually the same
structure for example sperm tail has all
the kind of Celia and your lungs are
very cuts off structure and in biology
and so we made it a system where you can
now play with these cells on your phone
so here see these these kind of cells in
action right if you follow more closely
you see kind of their swirling motion
you may see that extra roll around down
access right you may also see if you
follow some of these particles here
these are passive particles that go on
the rock undergo Brownian motion but at
the same time kind of the fluid-filled
moves around who has heard about low
Reynolds number hydrodynamics anyone
right so the thing is if you think about
water and swimming Raptors macroscopic
experience that we have right like with
vortices and all these things if you
kind of scaled down water in these kind
of length scales for these organisms
feels like swimming and honey so for
example mass and inertia doesn't play
any role as soon as they stop spoiling
the instantly stop and then all that
drives them is this diffusion if at all
right so very different world to live in
and very fascinating world and also
something too it's worthwhile to kind of
bring to laypeople to everyone right so
um to give you a little bit an
impression how we think from biophysics
perspective how an organism like this
works I appeared again like as you clean
up it is 11 flagellum and you can
basically abstract this thing as a
object which has this large elam and
basically can undergo
not all six degrees of motion but
primarily kind of drive forward roll
around its own axis and then kind of
execute its yaw and pitch motion you
have this I spot which is kind of
reading life in one direction I can
actually ask yourself questions like how
could you make a feedback loop between
these axes and the lights and so to make
something move very robustly towards the
light away from the light things like
that right but this kind of behavior
underlies then these setups so here's
the setup in real so this is 3d printed
microscopes actually as we were just
discussing before one of the undergrad
classes here at Stanford students build
something like this in order to learn a
of subject matters basically
constructing a device you have a little
microphylla chamber here um again where
these organisms live in your for LEDs
film from four sides so by actuating
each of them you can drive these cells
around and then there's some simple
objects that basically puts it on the
phone and then we can then make games
with that similar as you've seen before
but now a little bit advanced first of
all it's colored now right so they're
organisms on color but then we also drag
individual cells right you see how an
individual cell is this basically track
just and also amplify big on this side
and then the game involves basically
like using the joystick to shining light
from different direction order to orient
the cell or make the cell swim towards
this a virtual goal you can also
actually tab on the screen and select
the cell so there's kind of this playful
aspect but it's also this thing like I
mean can be basically there emphasize
something interesting and teach
something about biology and we can
because there's kind of scale bar here
right to see something about size you
see kind of the instantaneous velocity
of the cell um which is currently
tracked right you see how fast the cells
move you can also see something about
kind of in his close-up behavior another
game we kind of implemented this kind of
a Packman version okay we are kind of
trying to somehow make this cell to swim
along that sort of paths and if you
follow it for a while you see it's
actually not that easy right it's not
which brings an interesting point it's
not really really control a cell like
this but it's more like your controller
stimulus and then you kind of observe
how these cells behave you learn a lot
about kind of I don't know biological
noise and variability and other things
as well and actually the end of this
particular game you kind of even get
left with the kind of a trace of did you
follow which may be interesting to see
how well you did but also at the same
time contains lots of interesting
biophysics about these organisms right
to build this particular thing this the
whole building plan up there so it's
really intended to be affordable
accessible with very simple means you
have a simple electronic circuit some
sticker microfluidics um that you can
put it together sleeping with
microscopes and very simple eyepiece and
so ideas really that I don't know make
up spaces or whatever even in middle
school children could do this but ever
really I mean learning about these very
different subject matters and in a very
integrated manner and if you talk about
in mechatronics that we had before right
which is basically like this on the top
and here to be be more more inclusive
about different different metals um just
to say we can also do some more serious
activity like you away from these games
and just for example track cells just to
directly experiments and then formulate
hypotheses the cell for example an
average move faster than the light is on
or off right people generally assume it
moves faster than the light is on
because tries to escape the light but
it's usually not work on fines we also
um one is integrate something but from a
modeling perspective and so for those of
you know it is kind of a children
programming language scratch and so you
can actually animate cells that behave
like the real ones abstracted sense and
it's actually the whole code you need to
make a cell like this move so this kind
of the early stages we have shown this
to a number of teachers and kind of now
hope to somehow get this into a
classroom and actually being able to
refine it and seeing how this really
works or could be employed here some
some user studies or some children using
it this from some science feels like
different
different ages drawing what you see kind
of funny not like this eight-year-old
kind of drawing little legs kind of
realizing this is kind of a life
organism all dog they don't have last
night but you generally find this is
that about 10 11 years of age kind of
children grasp the concept which is also
kind of the atria children would use it
in school actually kind of read the
biology lessons kicking accordingly we
also asked a number of teachers help
them come to our lab and ask about
different aspects of what they think
they would find useful about a game set
up like this and most of them felt like
the building aspect and kind of being
able to kind of select individual cells
and making measurements is maybe the
most useful the idea by playing games
and maybe modeling I mean teachers
didn't express enthusiasm but that kind
of seemed to be of less less interest
and so as I said we're kind of not
trying to get this into into classrooms
and seeing how this would work and just
to kind of summarize this part this
particular setup we think we have a
system we can really learn on on three
different scales right you can make the
thing you can build it yourself you can
play with it and kind of playfully
explore but you also can make more
quantitative measurements and do kind of
more serious science like I mean how
fast we t cells move and how fast it'll
respond to light and other things ok so
another project using the same cells as
now that year how could we bring this to
museum space but also how could we get a
more intuitive interface even you may
have noticed or not like when I
explained rather LEDs are coming from
and how the lightest maybe some of you
real confused and also some of the
people are confused by playing it yes ok
so have you compared to other more
traditional teaching methods no so we
really need the Stanford undergrad
course where I let the students do these
kind of projects so that's kind of one
set of things and then we engage with
teachers and had a few kids try it but
we are we have not even reached a stage
where I said like it has employed in a
few classroom and work on itself like
your comparative things is even a level
beyond that we want to do but
without hmm yeah so basically i'm making
a more intuitive interface even so what
do you see here is again the same self
and this is a touchscreen and you see
his cell swimming and you can draw on
the touchscreen whatever you draw is
actually projected onto these cells and
as they kind of white light right so
they again kind of in this quasi to the
chamber as they avoid light you can kind
of capture capture them so just to rerun
it so just watch this one cell coming
from above the users drawing this kind
of light and sell kind of bounces back
right and it is actually very intuitive
because you what you do you see see
directly right so here's kind of again
capturing that sort of motion where now
the cell basically are bounces around
this virtual light circle so the setup
itself is this kind of shown here it's
essentially a normal and can even use a
pocket projector exchange the optics and
instead of projecting large you project
small and then you have a standout
standard microscope with everything
right and put back on the on the touch
screen and and established is this
feedback loop it's also important and
interesting if you have also an eyepiece
that people can actually look into the
microscope itself and see see what they
are doing what is showing here is the
same setup but now different
magnification right like what you can do
easily with objects is just zoom out and
also slightly defend light intensity
values and here for example you can also
see how these cells after some time
start accumulating on in certain colored
regions again kind of avoiding to the
blue light right yeah so this is the
this is the setup on his kind of this
pack projector some optics here's a
reservoir we actually keep to keep the
cells and can automatically flush them
and so that's flush them into the into
this chamber which is here which is also
important question about long-term
stability right like we are very used
from our computers we can turn them on
and off when this works for years so
with these systems we know that on a
couple of weeks time scale on the system
works well and then we have to exchange
all the organisms in part i mean when i
say exchange we have exchanged in there
but we exchange
much more frequently every couple of
hours also inside inside the chamber all
right but if you kind of wanted these
enable these kind of interactive
experiences you also need to make sure
that we deliver the use or something
that is robust right it is kind of an
ongoing ongoing thing and yeah and in
this thing you actually see the eyepiece
if you look through the eyepiece what
you see in there is the cell swimming
around but you also see kind of the
light that is projected I do okay so
just some some other things you can do
for this for example you can do
experiments like let it choose or the
user choose different colors and ask
them like how do they respond to
different colors it's of course a
question like how do we set overall
intensities but we made it such that it
respond to blue light but not to the
other ones right and so users can get
that sort of experience recognizing the
blue color you can also do an experiment
is a little bit a little bit more
challenging and trying to draw over the
front or the back of the cell and kind
of realizing where's the ispot it's
challenging the sense do to relax and
the whole system right the projector has
like the touch screen and suppose the
very hard texture to capture the back of
the cell but if you draw with a bag of
the cell the cell does not respond to
the only response of you draw over the
top over the front of it by the iceboat
says right so this kind of allows you
even to do experiments where you do a
subcellular resolution interrogation so
this is how we had tested it a couple of
times in a sample say a tech museum
we're essentially um you have the touch
screen here and then the set up next to
it people can actually look inside see
the whole whole equipment and then we
also Finn's eyepiece to look through and
we essentially left is kind of a to
science we're saying like look here or
draw here and then we were watching from
a part kind of doing user studies and
also post interviews like what would
people do um how would they interact
with that and just to show you some
example so usually people come up just
draw drawing something as this that's
what you do if you encounter a
touchscreen this is like a four-year-old
for example right like people writing
their names and then what they haven't
realized after some time is it is
actually stuff moving in the back and
there's actually two stuff that is
moving is somehow interacting with what
you have drawn right and then people
start playing more
the other aspect is usually one person
is occupying the touchscreen the other
person is nothing to do it and starts
looking through the eyepiece and
suddenly realizing that what the other
person is drawing is coming IPS and in
people's start having conversations with
each other so here's an example of one
user doing kind of an experiment kind of
self activated today or experimentation
the whole frame here sequence is livid
over two minutes and since person who
has walked up to the set up nobody can
see is initially the person kind of
capture the cell and then make it amazed
and try to see how this thing escapes
escapes the maze right and so what it
would argue is that we enabled a person
to making a microfluidic chip within two
minutes right without ever having done
anything on that kind of macroscopic
scale yeah and also mentioned before
like this importance like what you draw
on the screen you see sue the IPS and
then people kind of invented games like
this where like yeah draw something I
guess would you draw and the other way
around so I'm from abroad uh context
about museum experiences if you haven't
been to the exploratorium order the tech
museum if you go in there kind of
physics pace or so like you have lots of
like pendulums and other things you can
interact with and play and really get
prolonged engagement where people spend
like a couple of minutes parents with
their kids and in biology is actually
historically much harder to achieve I
mean you have by kind of macroscopic
petting zoos but the microscopic world
is usually so in non-interactive
microscope or if it's under actives and
it's more about controlling the
microscope but not under acting but
there with the actual living matter and
so I think we can really come through
these activities change that and here
let me just show you another project
which we started together in cooperation
with the exploratorium and it's the same
setup as you seen before but now we use
a connect to just record your whole body
motion just project this body motion in
there right you see remembers a child
dancing and then you see on the bigger
screen on the left kind of the
projection with these cells if you
follow this one closely and it's highly
sped up you see how the cells basically
avoid that person so to speak right and
also this this picture frame how you
and actually trap a few cells and move
them around and one thing I hadn't
appreciated before we start this project
is actually kind of like the organisms
and the human kind of meet each other in
the corresponding world right like you
see macroscopic yourself on a screen and
the cells at your scale but if you look
through the microscope you actually see
a little person dancing around in there
a bit with these cells and it's actually
what kids like to see it's like some
okay so these are kind of interactive
experiences on the phone museum setting
its kind of ongoing um so now um when I
get some other ideas about yeah like
poker programmability of these systems
and what could we do and just want to
say I'm for my personal history and I
was a teenager convulse inspired like
when the home computer revolution came
about and like kids having computers at
home primarily wanting them to play
games right parents thought like this is
educational and the end it was right guy
for example non programming through my
computer that I wanted to go gameplay um
and so the question is could we run this
base create something similar where you
I don't know have a device like this did
you could program what could you program
but then also maybe do some more more
serious thing and so this is an ongoing
project we are basically combine the two
setups that I showed before like the one
with the projector entered the LEDs
which means now we can manipulate
themselves from like in a global field
over this projector but and also give
some direction motion from the sides and
so here's an example what you now can do
um this is much more zoomed out right is
again this you clean ourselves but very
small you have this light pattern are
where you basically construct some sort
of barrier which is cells don't wanna
swim suit but in you also shine light
from one side and what you can do with
something like this is for example
concentrate cells right like shiny light
from here all the cells swim over there
and get captured in that sort of chamber
right and you can even call this you can
this whole thing would you see there you
can
rip this up and make a command out of it
concentrate cells like you call this
command and then this is this is what
happens you can do another command like
this which is kind of clear screen what
is it hmm hi okay so you basically do
the inverse thing right like trying to
light from here and kind of get get rid
of all the cells that are in there and
you have certain ways of manipulating
and I could ask yourself like what's a
source of enough programming language
that you want the more you could do with
it so for illustrative purposes we
basically program the game on this which
we call boxing bugs and boxes that
allows allows the demonstration of these
sort of capabilities and ideas so this
is kind of the startup mode the game
hasn't started yet but you kind of want
it clear part of the screen and kind of
removed some cells now this very extra
game starts and this game has basically
the goals to get these cells into here
the light is on from this direction and
what you as a player need to do is kind
of get rid of this berry on right like
and the player didn't do this so he lost
because all the cells accumulated here
but it did not move did not move in
there okay and now we're going to show
you um a movie like of three levels of
this that all kind of successful I know
why the hmm no ok so again first level
cells need to go india so you do it
successfully by racing this boundary the
timer runs up you have enough cells in
there which are tracked so good next
level is don't get any cells in there so
basically you need to draw a boundary do
this keep all the cells out very good
and then the third third level is where
you get the cells in here but not in
here and so again the lights are turned
on in a certain sequence and you
basically need to make a barrier here
and race there and all the cells and
I've been here but not not in there
right
and to actually have a just for that
overview kind of summarized this year
right this kind of shows how we can
reprogram levels are we can program
behaviors and again the first level the
light is coming from the left the
players asked to kind of get rid of this
barrier and goal is to get the cells
there and the next one the light comes
from the opposite side what you need to
do is actually draw a boundary in order
to prevent the cells from from being
there and then the third level is more
complicated because first this light is
on and all cells move down and then
later the other light is coming on all
the cells move there and you need either
kind of do do two operations hey um so
also to be honest so this is something
you can do in the lab space it's not yet
they aren't that you I don't know Kent
and can hand this off to someone and
play this with as much enthusiasm for
example as you do with a regular video
game which are which are highly polished
right but I think what this should show
is that these systems have a potential
for writing programming languages about
it on it and also doing higher level
higher level manipulation which may
inspire our similar things like early
home computers like enthusiasts now kind
of toying around with this but males
have more serious applications if you
kind of think of how we can manipulate
kind of micro robots or swarming robots
and microscopic scales which is also
kind of an active active area of
research right okay so and now let me
come on the second half of my talk later
hub more about this idea about cloud lab
so how can we actually now use these
these kind of systems to allow people to
interact over the web right and the
general ideas student or research or
sitting at home and running experiments
over the web right where you need to
have an actuator understand so and the
system is again a very similar basic
setup as before like four LEDs um this
is kind of the website you see the
camera view the live feed and then you
have destroy sticker this virtual
joystick which allows you to actuate
individual LEDs here you actually see an
external camera view
onto the microscope better chambers and
if you follow it for a while then you
see now when the light is coming from
here that after some time kind of cells
are start moving up right and you can
basically playfully playfully explore
just by going to a website and again
appreciate that the cells are not
deterministic there's all sorts of stuff
going on image data generally rich both
from a I mean for which makes really
room for discovery post for a kind of
student level but maybe also in the
future for for researchers and here is
like after the experiment you can
actually then download the data and
written some scripts rather than the
system automatically kind of tracks
tracks the cells for you presents all
these kind of track data catechin for
example importers matlab and then doing
analysis with that right so and we did a
number of user studies with this one of
them together with a big student who's
here the Stanford School of Education so
we went to middle school in San
Francisco and the students basically was
supposed to do two things kind of doing
some basic measurements and observations
but on the other hand and making some
modeling and we we kind of wanted to
supply this and the study was basically
designed such that within a 55-minute
class period students would do some pre
test and it would spend like five to ten
minutes working on this platform then
doing some analysis of the data and then
we had some modeling equipment so
modeling tool where they could kind of
try to fit a model to to their data
first thing is so in a pre study we
tried that all the students to their own
experiments and it actually did not work
so well part of the reason kind of
bandwidth limitation in a school setting
right and then also we not having enough
systems in parallel to supply all the
students with where we can actually
reside it too is that all the students
kind of frontal did an experiment
together well this is a system or the
web page was projected here and then all
the students at like hey let's see what
happens if you put it a joystick this
way and kind of ptosis in class
conversation over like five
and minutes and doing this experiment
together um so then the students in
pairs that the data analysis basically
then they all got access to this kind of
movie that it had just generated and we
also generated some other pre-processed
images very stacked a few images and
best kind of right away easier to see in
which direction cells are move and then
students were discussing do the move
away from the light to the light doing
some basic counting statistics and then
the last thing is we provided them with
this modeling interface where you have a
pre-recorded movie here in the
background and you're supposed to make
this thing you know this model kind of
matched the swimming path of a real
organism there's three parameters you
can q1 is the forward speed one is how
fast the organism spins around its own
axis and yellow third one how has strong
it responds to the light and if you kind
of choose these three parameters
correctly then you get a kind of a path
that looks looks pretty similar like
this sign and then students kind of
engaged in discussions and really to
emphasize like these these organisms
just have this one ice but so it can
only only sense light from one direction
whether then really need to do is
basically roll around the axis to kind
of explore the 3d space and that's an
also leads to these kind of undulating
motions as you can also see like kind of
de stumbling motion and yeah so the
students were doing this and then kind
of discussing and basically comparing
the experiment that they've done and
then the modeling side by side if you
kind of look of like enough to all
outcome um students learn the content we
had like 40 40 students about also
importantly the students kind of /
seemed perceived themselves as
successful they enjoyed activity and
fealty to learn something and also the
teachers feedback was positive in a
sense like that the students were more
lower than average during the average
class time and teacher also mentioned
there was was as a positive thing that
all these logistics about setting up the
biology I mean are kind of taking away
and that you can even in a much more
compressed class time to experiment and
kind of more sophisticated modeling
bring this about also emphasize I'm not
saying all teaching biology should now
run over the web right I think
zone is important as well and also pure
simulations have their place but I think
this could be a way to really deliver to
deliver certain types of in of
experiments that are currently not not
possible in school settings and if you
know think of like how could it really
scale up in the future um so here's
actually the setup or the setups and in
our labs each of these is kind of one of
these these microscopes right it's
basically webcam is four LEDs and then
an objective and then the ideas I mean
we set up a whole system we have
multiple users that can basically run
experiments and in parallel being routed
to the best ppu at a time setting up
cues and all these kind of things you
just need to build out to love people in
any given time too I mean access these D
solar systems and again to emphasize
since we can order monitor the system so
from time to time the system itself runs
a little experiments and checks whether
the cells are still responding properly
and if not kind of flushes fresh cells
in and if this one fails I mean then we
have to exchange it but by doing this we
can really have a system that runs
autonomously and it also really scales
from from a technical point of view and
yeah it just was mentioned this here you
kind of see how three different of these
systems are running right in you see for
example in this one there not many cells
in there so the system will
automatically recognize that and then
change something to it right really I'm
having this auto monitoring framework in
the back is important um so I know how
this is no really scale I'm from a cost
cost level and how useful is this and I
think this really can make a difference
nationwide and also worldwide in terms
of Education and just if you think about
it like these these experimental systems
are rather simple I mean set up maybe
cost like 250 bucks or so including like
raspberry pi and the webcam to kind of
operate them and then if you kind of
consider like these organisms very
simple and cheap sort of maintenance
costs also maybe two hundred fifty
dollars a year and assume that an
experiment usually has now experiment is
a minute long right
then you come up that you can run about
half a million experiments a year for
much less than a cent per experiment
right and any given systems and if you
now assume that I don't know you have
five million students and you guys every
are taking a certain biology course then
you can see how with 10 to 100 of such
system you could really kind of make a
difference in educational settings okay
and really at kind of a price point that
is low enough that would cost a couple
of dollars on to for example run a
biology class which is maybe even
cheaper than kind of ordering the
organisms to begin with okay and so
future ideas that then of course also
how to arm extend this first of all to
other stimulus stimuli so I think it
would be great to kind of integrate that
sort of system there is much more
intuitive surface of kind of drawing
colors over it and what you see on the
right is actually like an example of
different organisms so these are again
you Gleaner but then the big one is
Volvox is a multicellular kind of colony
and there's actually has under these
conditions positive phototaxis is
actually soon it's exactly the other way
if you follow it closely actually also
see how it generates on flow fields and
kind of makes all these cells it swim by
actually move around right so there's
some visions that in the long run are we
could really go to other organisms are
the stimuli Electric magnetic whatever
and those things could be built out okay
um now I want to tell you about another
example of such a system which actually
predates the one that I just talked
about which is very different in terms
of scales throughput also stimuli and
which i think is important to show
because also draw some lessons on like
comparing the two of how one should
actually design these these sort of
systems and this a cloud lab works with
a organism called free solemn it's a
slime mold so what do you see here as a
petri dish which is about this size and
in yellow you see this organism it's a
multinucleated single-celled organism
that kind of spreads around forms these
nice network
kind of grows in a dish and these red
dots that you see is animated we're
basically food was dropped by robot
remotely right so red is basically a
trail of food that has been placed and
then you can see how to organism
explores and then actually grows along
the food trailer there's also an
interesting organism in a sense that
kind of kind of development and behavior
right a kind of tightly coupled like the
shape of this organism and how it moves
or kind of the same thing so just just
to note the movie did you see here runs
on a course of about a day right so
basically the system takes an image
every every 10 minutes the system itself
that we built the prototype out of Legos
so kind of by petting robots we're on a
flatbed scanner we had like six such
dishes and then the robot would kind of
place these food drops based on users
under actions or user-defined foo
droplets on there and I rebuilt also
kind of a web interface out of it that
you could for example run on a phone or
via interface into two to do your
experiments and just to show you so this
is kind of to interface right like you
go to a website you pick your experiment
this is a dish which is currently
running so to speak and then you define
your food trail or food stimulus by for
example just drawing this out right and
this thing gets put in database and then
on the back end you have these these
these machines that now run these
experiments right so this gantry robot
is now taking up fluid and then a little
bit shaky you see here these individual
dishes now the scanner is taking a
picture and then these pictures are
basically disappeared individual user
then you can come back and see see what
you've done okay so you can get to set
up like the robot this is kind of to
pipette on it's all Lego except kind of
a simple syringe and we can actually um
reliably it spends fluid like down to 10
micro litre and this is kind of a server
rack which has three such machines each
of them running six experiment which
kind of was important for us to kind of
see how these things scales and how you
distribute many experiments about
multiple machines each machine runs
Mulder experiment
from architecture point of view is
actually different than you clean a
system before because the greener system
was always like with this live system
one use are checking out one system and
then kind of operating it directly on
well here you have a kind of an
asynchronous mode where each machine is
autonomously kind of checking once in a
while in the database where there's
something to do and the users also
interacting with the database just
putting the stimulus they are stimuli
there and looking at recent recent data
but the user never controls any system
directly this actually has the advantage
that if you now have set ups here the
run many experiments in parallel run
high throughput that you can really
disrepute multiple people's kind of work
of all over multiple setups okay and if
you think about modern biotechnology
what's going on there right now there's
lots of high-throughput equipment out
there right we're like you can have
experiments in parallel so rather one
scientist running a thousands thousands
experiments by not having thousands of
people run one experiment each they're
kind of making these these couplings so
you see some examples where the students
did when we tested it in a course kind
of trying different things like how well
these dis organism responds to food
whether they can actually make the
organism kind of split right what
happens if you give to organism
different sizes of food like what the
organism be able to kind of discriminate
between that then is some homework kind
of doing some fractal analysis and
modeling and other things so here for
example is a series where a student made
some observations of how organisms of
different size the shape actually
depends and then made basically
biophysical model that would kind of
capture this important aspect of all
these kind of online system is also kind
of the potential for doing learning
analytics and this log data and just to
give you a glimpse of dad for this
particular system so this kind of the 10
week period over that the course ran
each of these blocks is in individual
experiment each of this red bar is when
the student logged in right this was
usually when the experiment was running
and this was then later looking back at
activity arm and then also student could
actually look which is shown in pink at
other people's data
the end of the quarter like a profile of
how individual students how many
experiments they run how often they
logged in and these are like four
different students right and just
looking at it you see different profiles
for example with this student here the
blue bars which always go from the first
time to the last time the experiment was
done a much shorter so this is student
who usually did an experiment only based
on the last experiment but never look
much further back by the others did we
see you soon on the top we looked at
lots of other people's data right so
then we really lifted what's all in this
kind of data but this is potential to
really understand in track how how do
people do experiments how do the
students learn right and this I guess
something that you guys aren't very
familiar with yeah and here's some
simpler robot we now try to kind of also
get into schools we can do some simple
experiments doing concentration
gradients with food colors which is
something that children like and thereby
or if you're initially kind of is
robotics things right like it's not only
about robots that kind of can move
around but it's also how could we make
robots on spire on building robots and
interacting with robots that do kind of
life science research right kind of to
bring these these two together so the
general utility for these kind of clout
experimentation setups on when we talked
about a lot now about education right I
think that's potential and as one of the
next project is like having a dedicated
small set of real scientists interacting
with a platform like this and seeing
what would they discover but would they
what kind of research what they do you
could hope that has report equipment is
better utilized and actually not some
companies out there that kind of cloud
lab companies for pharmaceuticals and
and also I caddy me out to run
experiments for you and then as this
whole notion of citizen science where
for example Eternals also here was
developed at Stanford like allowing
people to really contribute to the
research by running their own
experiments and analyzing right so if
you kind of abstract from from this a
little bit like what kind of equipment
does it take to enable interactivity um
we now
first of all of course it needs biology
always needs a sensor needs an actuator
almost trivial and so we not call this
kind of a biotic processing unit similar
um if you think about BP use or CPU CPUs
Oh GPUs right and will also be very
useful to have each of these setups or
these people use in the acting as a
digital input and output channel right i
mean you can imagine making this an
activity work by pipetting with your
hand or visual inspection but if you
really kind of fold this sort of
paradigm that you can really integrate
this in any sort of existing a framework
right for example a web interface so
yeah so that's kind of the definition of
a BP you digitally input output and then
you have biology in the middle that you
can both measure and stimulate right and
so you could kind of treat it as any
sort of electronic device that you have
performance metrics of such a device
would be interesting right like imagine
you want to deliver education at scale
for the u.s. how do you do this which
kind of device should you choose which
has the most and activity going and you
could of course a let's just see how
what's the throughput of the projector
and the camera itself right and this is
not very meaningful because if there's
no biology in the middle then there's no
interactivity and so the truth what may
be best is kind of doing a mutual
information matter where you basically
look at if you make a stimuli how much
of this simulate can you read back from
the response that you see right um and
just to illustrate this is a little bit
so if we have for example on two LEDs
from the side we have to clean ourselves
you apply stimulus and response time is
on a scale of 10 seconds you can
basically have a mutual information like
one bit per 10 seconds kind of seeing
that sort of stimulus if you have oily
DS you kind of doubled that right if you
have this kind of projector system at
you maybe can't I'll up and have
different people running on different
parts of it
you may become more like 30 bits to 10
seconds if on the other extreme we look
at this force our own system right which
had a much lower throughput we only got
an image like every 10 minutes or
whatever you your way lower than that
right and I think having those sort of
kind of course measure could really be
informative of what to do in order to
enable interactivity at scale and also
cost so some other comments um there's a
question about ethics here which is
sometimes get asked especially when we
make games out of these systems just a
name if you have these objections right
like animal welfare do we respect life
when we play with them are we playing
God the yuck factor so some people may
say oh it crosses me out seeing these
cells there's a slippery slope right now
nowadays we do it with cells but do we
later do it with monkeys I'm trivial
pursuit right this kind of a waste of
taxpayers money public safety maybe
superbug evolves by we play game ethics
right all these games kind of
well-constructed and playful what would
happen if we do citizen science on this
and someone makes a discovery who owns
it right today a bunch of things you can
ask and so together with David Magnus
wrote a piece couple of years ago and
kind of address these issues thinking
it's fine and to do this kind of in this
microscopic organism given that we
follow a few guidelines first of all no
pain no harm you should engage with the
public and saying what we do is good
right for example on being educational
informing the public about modern
biotechnology respecting life so I mean
what does it mean to have a respectful
interaction with the single-celled
organism but you can ask yourself and of
course respected play all right like
where everyone back to the system you
want to give something positive to them
yeah and then kind of really circling
back to to to my interests lights
between comparing biotechnology and
computing technology right you can say
each of these fields went to kind of the
early really foundational discoveries
like for example the quantum mechanics
and the golden years right and then we
had the transistor and integrated
circuit and similar thing you can see
like the structure of DNA DNA
methylation of these kind of
um circuits that we can now build other
microphysics or kind of synthetic so
good and if you want to say so you can
draw a correlation line and find some
sort of a 50-year relationship between
them and if you look where games then
writes always the debate where was the
first video game but could kind of see
that that's sort of a 50-year
relationship and then we can also ask
like what was the time when devices
really came into households and people
were using it and based on that it
should not be that far away so it should
have the next five to ten years if you
really think about it now about your
phones smartphones that you have with
you right there's already certain bio
measures in there but heart rates and
other things and won't be long that I
mean they're already like if you have
blood sugar level measurements right
won't be long that these things have
microvidia devices integrated and that
we then can play these kind of things on
our phones maybe another way of getting
these things in everyone's hands is kind
of the cloud labs that I talked about
okay so okay so bright future ahead and
so let me thank my lab so which is over
there half of them works on that the
other half works on more conventional
life sciences so to speak and just to
summarize I told you about interactive
biotechnology we have a number of
platforms and we spend a long time I'm
kind of making them robust and freely
programmable and there's kind of an
ongoing theme we use them kind of in
different sort of setups right self
builder kit museums clouds this concept
of this biotic processing unit is
something an abstraction of a device
that then basically everyone could use
even if that person wouldn't know
anything about biology and applications
now I mean talked a lot about education
but the question about research next and
going into micro robotics or what other
kind of things could be manipulated
actually and these sort of scales okay
and so if anyone here would like to
interact with me my lab more
collaborative way or more formal more
informal way always happy to talk always
interested to have a good people also
want to point out that this is the heat
it was actually a CS student who made a
brief jump
fungsi s into by engineering or I think
he's doing very wrong hazing having fun
doing these kind of things okay thank
you very much questions yeah examples
missiles firm and the sensitivity was
like and their motion was the flagellum
and the question is can be plated other
things where each week to use light to
open ion channels or use light to play
with DNA and have different genes been
expressed then you the language on top
of it like an interactive language and
start mixing things that you open ion
channels express jeans and put things
together in multiple different cells to
make really complicated systems like
they go yes no innovation would love to
do all of this the thing is we are happy
to have a have a robust system now to
just relies on a wild-type organism we
don't have to do any genetic
manipulation other things right now the
thing let's focus primarily on this
organism and run with this because it's
stable any new organism any new
manipulation i mean that's labeled as
logistics making robust but in the
future i'm sure we'll come right like
many more types of interactions and
organisms biological materials will be
used when we're getting started how long
did it take you to find this creature
that you how many help you to try so so
it was pretty fast like the very first
game i showed you this paramecia it was
good brother I don't know it took a
couple of weeks and we're happy with
that but then it kind of hit a roadblock
because they weren't stable enough
long-term and it took think quite some
soul searching and trying lots of
different things until we ended up with
the with this organism the way worked in
the end like I went to school supply
company bought everything I got put it
on my desk whatever had survived after
months without doing anything that's
what I work with and and having a strong
stimulus response right like shining
light on your way CCU response yeah it's
used your local park would you have yes
you're very only used in solidification
you find them in your pawns they are
safe to eat taking companies that make
you lean our cookies and I think Japan
we can buy them they're supposed to be
very nutritious and I haven't tried them
it seems like almost the future
iteration of you know male home ant farm
when some ways or the like the
caterpillar to butterfly think that mean
and I'm wondering many ways those were
pitched as sort of you can watch it and
maybe there was some there was some
lesson like you know sages the crystals
and all these kinds of things but I've
got like it was more just like that a
close-up experience I wondering you is
your point of view that you want that
kind of thing or are you intending these
more to supplement very specific like
pedagogical goals in science or biology
education so for example like what
what's specific if that's the Russian
you what's the specific kind of lesson
that you want something to draw out
these games around you know light
sensitivity or flagellum like what what
are the concepts you're trying okay or
is it just sort of giving an intuition
and access okay so the first thing I'm
very strong about interactivity right I
do something and I both our vocals and
can make those organisms to something
and the other thing is you these are
just as an example of many things you
can learn right if you want to teach
someone like how how does microbiology
work I mean you can pick one organism
and study it in depth and you can show a
picture about other organs Marshall
movie right if you want to demonstrate
how can you make measurements and
statistics on a living system I mean you
can use Houston so how do you make model
so i think this they can really
supplement many more things or just
choosing choosing the single one so
there was a question with a kind of
similar to michael's but yet along these
lines of i guess I'm wondering it uh
what what you guys were doing when you
had or have you thought about other
types of material that you can use in
the class
room in terms of the types of relating
that to these specific you know learning
goals or other things like that because
it seems like so exciting to use this
and that I think there seems like
there's a lot of these possibilities but
I'm wondering what are the limitations
you see in like the specific organisms
your uni now or is it yeah I guess if
you could speak a little bit too as you
look to expand this what are like the
next steps in terms of is it the
organism that needs a change or is it
the the input that needs a change or how
do you do so we're just yeah you wanna
make things work you need to have a few
features like one is you want to have
responses are ready for other fast right
if you see something in five seconds
better than in an hour you won't have
something that's very stable and has low
logistics and to them both keeping it
alive or keeping it happy right and then
you want to have some easy easy to use
stimulus right like light is easy to
turn on and off but if you have for
example chemicals all right like that
you flow in how do you get rid of the
chemicals again so sure what I forgot
something but a few things that make it
logistically extremely easy or make
every project extremely hard and they
would love to have more organized and
more stimuli and things like that in the
future but as i said before right now
let's just primarily focus on this
organism and let's go more demonstrate
the application so i had like
demonstrated we can do a coward lab at a
scale and it's educationally effective
yeah i guess this is related to these
last two questions but well really are
the pedagogical goals of the games is it
you know dusted in iraq with the
creatures duration or something deeper
and are you achieving those goals okay
then i personally came from the game
idea and maybe in retrospect I should
have thought about interaction and just
games as a sub part of this rather than
games and so I kind of evolved along
with that whether we meet these
education goals I mean that's really the
question that's only something we get
into right I make sure you like this
this data from this study live in San
Francisco middle school right i mean we
see two children learn so
children respond positively to teachers
have positive things to say but this I
mean this is basically starting right
and whether whether a game itself I mean
I believe in the pedagogical value of
games many many aspects or more general
just the capability of interacting right
to do playfully explore i think is very
important but we would need to show this
still right and some of the teachers
that i showed you earlier some of the
teacher was most skeptical whether the
game is really the right way to go maybe
the most standard biology experiment is
just important thing to do have a
simulation of there would be a lot
easier to talk about along here to this
very important point which I maybe
didn't make it well so there's certain
studies showing that if you tell people
like this is a life this is real this is
simulated that on certain conditions
they respond much more with much more
interest if they know it's alive it was
also in a museum we actually where we
had to set up next to it we kind of also
removed the set up so they only saw the
screen and then asked people and then
many people then didn't realize it was
alive and it was much less interested in
it right um so simulations certainly
have a place and they are much better
augmenting certain things may be much
cheaper to do things like that but on
certain conditions having the life thing
is bleached much deeper engagement more
interest the other virtual reality labs
on campus much seems like there could be
some cool stuff mugabe right I'm mad
yeah but I'm none of the systems kept
his England not who he proved his own
sayings
can we deliver box like this p pu which
is just digital in the biology is living
in there but whatever like in a virtual
reality level can just treat as any
other electronic device something sort
of physics engine if you kind of can
enable that I mean then I hope that
people make interesting stuff with that
it seems like your main punches your
activity and the fact that it's real and
so if you use Virtual Reality like those
are that's like kind of the
accommodation that it makes like
interactivity in real life could be
really cool no question yes I'm kind of
thinking like could even animate like
that enemy kind of could you somehow
swims through this surah space with her
oculus rift I would like to see that I
would like to do that
you